greetings this is Rob Sanders from
simply learned and today we're going to
talk about SEO tips and tricks so let's
get started and throughout this series
we're gonna have a few tips to share
with you and we'll start out with tip
number one up for smarter ways to do
keyword research and so if you listen to
any of our SEO tutorials in the past you
know that keyword research is the first
step but the most crucial step in
starting SEO so when we do keyword
research we want to be able to basically
find keywords that we feel are relevant
to our business that we want to be found
on search for and so here are a few tips
that can help you do that research in a
more efficient manner the first thing we
want to do is identify a list of
keywords that are relevant so we only
want to focus on relevant keywords for a
business that's a given so what I would
suggest is the best practice may be you
know put down some of those keywords in
a spreadsheet so think of them as a
theme of keywords because when you do
research you're going to want to include
a theme of key words relating to one
another so you can pick the best ones
out of that theme and so as an example
if we have a company that sells dried
figs in a spreadsheet as an example if I
show you a spreadsheet maybe we want to
focus in on just dried fig and maybe we
want to focus on on dried fig recipes so
go ahead and put those in a column you
know some of these keywords that you
know you want to be found for so that's
really the first step they need to be
relevant so put them in a spreadsheet so
that you can build keywords around that
list then we want to choose keywords and
when we choose keywords we want to have
some criteria around shoes in them and
so we always want to choose keywords
with a lot of volume and what I mean by
volume I mean how many people on average
type in that keyword or a related
keyword per month the second criteria is
the keyword a product fit meaning you
know is the keyword relevant you always
want to stay true to relevancy the third
is commercial intent what is the
tenth of the keyword is it trying to get
us a sale is it answering a question so
what is the intent of that keyword and
then last its difficulty so we want to
definitely take a look at how difficult
a keyword is to rank for on organic
search so that's some of the criteria
you may have some additional criteria
that you want to use but this is the
criteria basically for choosing keywords
so again we want to prefer keywords with
high volume you want to be careful of
seasonality
so remember seasonality in this example
Christmas tree you're only gonna have a
spike you know during the winter or
excuse me the October November December
months so be careful of seasonality when
choosing high-volume keywords and again
keywords that are relevant to your
product even though it doesn't have much
search volume relevancy oh we strumpf
volume or any other metric commercial
intent so we want to look at keywords
that for example have Buy in them they
may have low search volume but if
somebody's typing in that keyword then
we can insinuate that the consumer who
type in that keyword is ready to make
the purchase so we want to look at what
the intent is of that keyword and then
again the difficulty always up for
keywords that have low difficulty or
competition and so in order to get these
metrics we can use third-party tools and
I'm going to show you a couple of
examples of third-party tools you can
use that will give you some of this
information so first Tolle I'm going to
show you is Google ads keyword planner
so if I'm having Google Ads account I
could simply go to tools and then choose
the keyword planner and from there I
want to find new keywords so if I choose
the keyword dried figs cuz that's the
keyword I put in my spreadsheet that I'm
interested in optimizing for and then
maybe drive fake recipes that was the
other keyword theme so if I enter those
two keywords in just to begin with
basically what Google is going to give
me is the average search monthly volume
so here I can see dried figs I have an
average monthly search volume
means on average over the last 12 months
that's how many people have typed in
that keyword here I can see a little bit
of a trend I just hover my mouse over
that graph I can see again for
seasonality impact if there is any
seasonality what the volume is on
average per month then I can see the
competition is high and because this is
Google ads because it's paid search
they're gonna give me a sense or an idea
of what I should be bidding on that
keyword now that's another topic for
another day but it's good information to
have because if you're not ranking for a
keyword you could decide to bid on it
for paid search so don't discard the
bidding information go ahead and put it
in a spreadsheet for later use for now
we're focused in on keywords and
irrelevant how much volume how much
competition okay
so once I get this information here I
can simply go back to my spreadsheet and
put that information in there what's the
volume for dried fig what is the
competition now for competition notice
that Google Ads gives us a high or low
now if you're trying to measure ratio
between volume and competition we want
to get an actual sense of what that
competition is so what I always do is
the best practice is go into Google
search if I go to Google search and I
type in dried figs I'm gonna see the
actual volume is thirty four million
five hundred thousand so I can see
that's the actual search volume for this
particular keyword however if I add a
syntax called
all in title before that keyword with
the colon space and then hit enter then
I can see the actual volume reduces to
thirty one thousand and basically what
this tells me is that thirty one
thousand listings results have the
keyword dried figs in the title tag so
if a webpage has dried fig our targeted
keyword in the title tag then ideally we
caná-- sinuate that that page is trying
to rank for that keyword so therefore in
order for us to rank number one on
Google we have to jump over 31,000
results so we want to be able to include
this information into our keyword
analysis so if I go into
keyword analysis here and I go ahead and
enter in that information so what's my
keyword my keyword is dried figs okay my
volume was 8100 my competition was
31,000 and so that gives me a ratio of
81 divided by 31,000 I make that into a
percentage basically 26% so that's my
keyword effectiveness index or Kei or
ratio between volume and competition and
so that's an way that you can gather
information is by using Google Ads enter
the information into a spreadsheet and
then sort all your data by Kei you could
sort it by volume you could sort of my
competition all these metrics matter
alternatively as another tool you can
use moss so Moz has a keyword Explorer
tool okay so if I type in the keyword
dried figs I'm focusing on the United
States I could see that Moz says hey
look there's anywhere between forty
three hundred and sixty five hundred in
terms of volume out of a hundred the
difficulties forty-one and so I can
expect a click-through rate of you know
forty one percent and so basically a
great thing about Moz is keyword
Explorer tool is I can also look at the
surfer analysis search engine results
pages what search stands for and I can
analyze the SERP for a particular
keyword in Moz so I want to be able to
understand what my competitions doing so
here I can see if I'm really want to try
and optimize for that keyword I can see
what the other pages are ranked for that
keyword in the on page one I can also
see what local results show up for that
keyword so here I can see that we have a
number of different sites listed here so
if we want to be number one these are
the sites that are basically above us
that we need to climb over to be number
one on Google so I find that the keyword
Explorer tool in Moz is very helpful for
understanding your competition as well
as getting a alternative check on volume
and competition or difficulty if you
will and so remember we want to identify
a list of key
irrelevant I can't stress that enough we
want to choose keywords based on
difficulty we want to choose keywords
based on volume on a commercial intent
and more important relevancy we can also
to identify trends from a site search
query like Amazon and know what your
competitors are ranking for so we can
also go back into Moz and we can see
just by typing in some of the keywords
we're focusing on we can see if our
competitors are ranking for the same
keywords just by using that keyword
Explorer tool and then another thing we
want to look at is LSI or latent
semantic indexing so it's a fancy word
which basically means we want to find
keywords related to the topic of the
page or trying to optimize so if there
are other keywords on that page then you
could sway it in that direction and so
when it comes to choosing keywords you
want to choose always a primary and
secondary keyword and so if we go back
to our spreadsheet
it doesn't necessarily always have to be
just one keyword it doesn't necessarily
be dried figs we could choose another
keyword that has a good volume to
competition ratio so we want to choose
keywords that are always relevant
and if we're analyzing nothing but
relevant keywords then we want to be
able to choose keywords that have a good
ratio between volume and competition so
you always want to choose at least two
keywords per page we could also stay up
to date on industry news as well hope
you learn new jargon so it doesn't hurt
to subscribe to sites like search engine
watch or search engine land they have
lots of good tips so here I'll show you
with that one of those sites look like
if I simply just go to search engine
watch com I find this is a good resource
to stay up on the latest news when it
comes to search engines here we can see
the why SEO and front-end developers are
the perfect search marketing team
another article about optimizing your
channel YouTube channel five easy steps
so there's a lot of information here on
search engine watch that pertain to SEO
and keyword research we could also look
at other third-party sites like
Wikipedia Reddit and core for example so
if I go to Cora I can do a search for
dried figs
I could see what's being written about
that topic so that should give me some
ideas to build a keyword a list around
so for example the health benefits of
dried figs okay our dry figs say for
diabetes best ways to eat dry figs so
those are all good keyword themes that
we could build a keyword list around and
I did that simply just by typing in
dried figs encore so that's a good tip
for you to leverage when you're trying
to build out a keyword list okay let's
talk about tip number two which is
publish high quality content to get more
traffic to your website so it's all
about content so we've already done the
keyword research we still need to kind
of merge the two when we talk about
merging the two it's not just building
content around those keywords it's much
more than that when it comes to SEO and
so that's why we always talk about high
quality content so let's talk about some
of the tips that can help you create
high quality content so first tip is we
want to be able to publish longer and
engaging content longer and engaging
content tends to rank higher on Google
why because you have more content to
work with and when you have more content
to work with you can optimize it you can
structure it you can insert different
assets like videos and images and by
keeping it long you're gonna likely keep
it engaging and so Google tends to lean
in favor of content that is well
organized structured and long because it
is more likely to be engaging for the
end user we definitely want to include
there's target keywords so you want to
be able to you know insert those
keywords into those meta tag
descriptions into those title tags into
those alt tags but you want to work them
in naturally you don't want to force
anything content should be naturally
written because if it's naturally
written it's gonna be engaging so we
want to use LSI keywords in the content
so LSI or basically latent semantic
indexing basically just means different
terms and concepts related to your
target keywords so feel free to use
is terms that are similar to what you're
currently using these keywords can
definitely be used for SEO because they
can create more visibility and
potentially higher rankings because it
gives you an opportunity to use keywords
that are natural and then work for
different variations and let's look at
an example so if you're optimizing an
e-commerce category page and your
keyword is one mix used for men so we
want to use keywords closely related to
one mix shoes for men for example
running shoes for men or sport running
shoes for men outdoor sport shoes or
air-cushion shoes let's take a look at
example of Amazon so if I go to Amazon I
can see the one mixed shoes for men page
and if I look at this page I can see a
lot of product and each product has
basically some content associated with
it
ie the title of the particular product
and so you want to be able to use
different descriptors for this
particular product for example men's
running shoes or breathable lightweight
gym sports shoes or lightweight casual
sneakers or walking casual sneaker
all of these are LSI related keywords
they are similar to what we're trying to
optimize for so you don't necessarily
always have to be brand heavy or stick
with one keyword you could definitely
show variation especially on the
e-commerce side if you're dealing with
different products so we want to make
the content readable with the help of
visuals subtitles and bullet points so
if your e-commerce you want to make sure
that page is laid out properly easy to
read your here I could see the
descriptor along with the title all kind
of merge together and so there's no
break out of okay this is the product
name this description it's kind of one
all-in-one which I like it just makes it
more natural sounding okay and you can
see these are all broken out pretty well
laid out page and Amazon is more or less
you know consistent in terms of how
their pages are laid out so make it
readable add visuals add subtitles add
bullet points it helps break out a lot
of the content especially if you have a
long
amount of content or a large amount of
content so the use of subtitles bullet
points and visuals will help break it
out structure it and make it more
engaging for the end user you definitely
want to write an effective and organized
content in order to reduce the bounce
rate so there is correlation between
engagement and bounce rate the more you
structure the more you add visuals the
more you add subtitles the more engaged
somebody's going to be the less likely
they are to bounce from the page we also
want to share customer reviews and
ratings so if you have a webpage you
sell product even if you don't sell
products it's always good to have
testimonials or some type of customer
review so if we go back to our example
on Amazon and we clicked on a product
one of the running shoe products we look
here we can see the image we can see
kind of the description well I may not
be so interested in buying this product
I want to know a little bit more about
it well that's where the breaking point
comes and that's where the decision
factor comes in where if I read other
reviews then I can possibly have my mind
made up to buy this product so here I
can see that not only there were reviews
but there's testimonials so I can see
that here you can see that there's a lot
of stars and you can see the kind of the
review title these running shoes are
very comfortable and lightweight so you
have a lot of different feedback and so
reading customer reviews is always
helpful because even though you're
making the decision and kind of will
help sway you in one direction or
another at least it does for me so
that's the beauty of a customer review
and a rating we want to be able to use
those to our advantage and then you want
to be able to update your content on a
regular basis so and that goes for
testimonials and reviews you want to
make sure you're always getting reviews
if you're always getting reviews then
that's just adding to the particular
product and so if you're always updating
your content and regular basis as well
then Google's going to be able to see
that and Google likes fresh content okay
we also want to include the benefits of
the product so if you're selling a
product any product you always want to
include the benefits you want to do as
much as you can to make your product
engage into the end user
enticing so that they can buy it so in a
dish
the customer reviews are adding content
about the product you want to include
benefits so if we go back to Amazon here
we could see Amazon lists a lot of the
benefits or one mix in this case list a
lot of the benefits so here you can see
all the descriptors about the particular
products it's got rubber so it's got a
breathable textile lighting you get free
hot quality socks with every shoe so
these are some of the features and if we
continue to scroll down we can see some
of the details about the fabric type
specifics about the fabric and a lot of
information on this product page even a
sizing chart so a lot of different
features that will help the end user
make the decision so don't hold back add
as much information as you possibly can
as much information as you have
available
it doesn't hurt because in the end what
you're trying to do from a product
perspective to sell the product and you
can't really sell it unless you have
information that's going to convince the
user that this product is what they want
to buy so include the warranty size
recommendation return policy and some
offers so it should all be listed on the
page easy for the end-user to see so
can't stress it enough provide as much
product information as possible
go back here here it has a sizing chart
what colors are available against some
of the descriptors if I scroll down here
I can see some more of the benefits you
know waffle rubber outsole soft
deodorant insole again fabric type it's
got all sorts of information
it's got images about the fabric itself
the shoe itself how its structured so a
lot of information about this and it
even does a comparison and so there's a
lot of information about this particular
product so don't hold back at as much as
you can to give Vince the end user so in
the case the one makes on Amazon you
know they had a sizing chart you know
they had an FAQ be an additional
information what other products that
customers view from one mix and then
testimonial so these are some of the
basic bits of information you want to
add on your page if you don't have
customer reviews it's okay ad FAQ in its
place again the end result is to
convince the customer to purchase the
product and then build a comprehensive
internal linking structure of web pages
so every product page should link to
similar products so if I go back here
here I can see other products from one
mix so you should always have a linking
structure so that if the end user
doesn't want to particularly buy that
particular product then you have links
available so they can go to another page
and then add different varieties and
related short videos of the product so
if we go back to our product page
you know they have different varieties
that they're showcasing here they have
the size chart they even have a size
convertible chart so if you're dealing
with metrics you can go over to US
metrics be vice versa you can add a
video you know show a video if you're
selling running shoes so a video
somebody working out you know doesn't
have to be a full-blown commercial per
se but it could be a short 30-second
video of what the shoe looks like on
somebody else's feet so that they could
see somebody walking with those shoes on
so video doesn't have to be a big
production you could do it right from
your phone so review your content before
you publish this goes without saying you
want to do that just you make sure you
include everything possible because when
the content does get published
remember Google's going to index that
content when they index it it's going to
show up in the search results so we want
to make sure we have all the information
readily available not only for the
end-user but for Google as well we want
to be able to analyze our meta tags and
URL to improve click-through rates so
this is important because the meta tags
ie the title tag in the meta description
and the URL is what shows up in Google
search results so we have title tags the
first that's the first important element
that's what shows up in the search
results so what we want to do is we want
to optimize the title tag and when we
optimize it we want to use modifiers and
when I say modifiers I mean you know
feel free to use the word best or cash
back or free shipping or discount so for
example if you're selling running shoes
25 best sneakers or
up to 70% off or free shipping or buy
shoes on discount very action-oriented
but you know what includes these
modifiers that are going to help
somebody click on that link so some tips
for optimizing the title tag in addition
the modifiers we want to watch the title
length and we want to include there's
target keywords in the title tag though
remember you're likely going to have two
keywords to work with you want to have
at least one of those keywords in your
title tag so with the modifier you know
up to 60 to 65 characters in length with
that targeted keyword should get you a
good title tag that's gonna get somebody
to click on it so let's look at an
example so if I type them a keyword best
recipes for dried figs you know here I
can scroll down here's my title tag
stands out my URL is right underneath
that and underneath the URL bar is the
meta description and so here I can see
some modifiers 188 best autumn dried
fake recipes or 25 fantastic fig recipes
or 10 best cooking dried fig recipes so
these are all modifiers they're gonna
help somebody get the click get them to
click on your link and go to your
website so when you don't hit the 65
character limit name if you go over that
Google is going to cut off the title
text so we want to avoid that at all
possible so the whole idea is you know
like 10 best cooking dried fig recipes
by yummly
that's a good enticing title tag ok
takes into account a modifier includes
the targeted keyword and is under the 65
character count some additional tips for
writing meta description we always want
to provide a unique description for each
web page of the website so no duplicate
meta tag descriptions every page you
needs to be unique then we also want to
be specific about what we're offering so
if you have say you're selling
headphones and you have a particular set
of headphones from a different specific
brand include that in the meta
description if you have that particular
product from that brand on sale include
that in the meta description so you want
to be as specific as possible the whole
idea behind
description is to describe the page but
also to get the end-user to click on
your link so here's an example of using
modifiers and describing a page if we
look at Amazon again we can see this
example here and if we look at it on
Google search results if I type in
Amazon Bluetooth headsets $10 or on sale
here we can see a lot of Amazon listings
in Google search here you can see they
use some modifiers in the title tag and
also in the meta description here we can
see that you know this particular
headset Bluetooth headset is on sale 50%
off so if something's on sale feel free
to include it beasts descriptive about
the page let people know where they're
going and use those modifiers don't be
afraid to use numbers in the meta
description even if it's the price
itself even if it's not on sale but it
is the price included it's not going to
hurt the more information you can
include in a meta description the better
chance you have of somebody clicking on
that link use numbers symbols you know
percentages off always help use catchy
words like discount or cashback you're
competing with other listings on the
page so if you have something on sale if
it's on clearance list then it's on
clearance here I can see they even
included the coupon code so feel free to
list as much specific information about
that page as possible the whole idea is
you're competing with your own webpages
but in other cases with competitors so
the Meta Description along with the
title tag and the URL helps separate out
you from the rest of the listings on
search engine results and we don't want
a keyword stuff we want to keep it
within a hundred sixty something
characters or 160 sixty-five characters
because Google will break off the Meta
Description just like they do with the
title tag and so we want lean natural
written meta descriptions that separate
you from the competition
so that means including the keywords
when making sure those keywords are
naturally included in the meta
description so if I go back again to
valley fig comm and I could see the
meta-description hey welcome to the best
resource online for dried fig recipes
savory sweet snacks or healthy dried fig
recipes we've got it all start cooking
with FIGS and so it's natural sounding
it does include the key word it's not
keyword stuffing its natural sounding
that's hopefully going to get that
person to click on this particular
website let's turn our attention to the
URL so we want to make sure that the URL
is basically taking into account best
practices so if we take a look at this
particular URL here it doesn't
necessarily look as attractive as we
would like so first of all I don't
understand some of it so that makes it
unpleasant boring and messy to say the
least so you want your rao's that you
know basically are clean and
understandable so in other words we want
to make them SEO friendly because if
they're SEO friendly somebody
understands the URL then they're likely
going to click on it so the old rule of
thumb is if you can read the URL then
the search engines can read the URL so
here are some tips for creating friendly
URLs for SEO make it readable you want
to include the target keyword in the URL
so if it's dried figs your route should
include dried figs if it's dried fig
recipes make sure it's dried fig recipes
now avoid using too many subdirectories
in the URLs so we want to keep it as
close as possible to the root directory
and match the URLs to titles most of the
time so let's go back to our example
here here we can see this is valley fig
DICOM such recipes not necessarily dried
fig recipes but recipes nonetheless it's
in the root directory okay so at all
cost now this is in some cases
unavoidable given that you may be
dealing with an e-commerce website
that's calling you know content from a
database so if it that is the case
you're gonna have some dynamic
parameters in the URL which is fine just
make sure you avoid having too many of
those dynamic parameters it's
understandable that parameters but the
rule of thumb generally is no more than
two different parameters in the URL so
prefer to create sure
yowls that's really the way to go the
shorter the better is the role of them
and you know if you're going to break up
the URL then use hyphens instead of
underscores it's just cleaner it's a
more understandable search engines tend
to read it a little bit easier if it's -
so here's what a friendly URL looks like
for search you got your domain you got a
subcategory broken up with a hyphen and
then the product so that's like just a
clean you're off for a particular
ecommerce site that has categories and
subcategories so again we got amazon.com
your category can be electronics your
subcategory could be earphones and your
product could be boat earphones it's
that simple let's start with talking
about Rich Snippets this is tip number
four so we want to add Rich Snippets to
improve your website's visibility on
SERPs so tip number four is all about
Rich Snippets so let's start out by
asking ourselves what is a rich snippet
so rich snippet is simply just a term
used to describe structured data markup
that you as a website owner can add to
your HTML so hypertext markup language
or HTML is what is basically constructs
a page so if we can add more information
to that that will in turn allows search
engines like Google to better understand
the information that's on that web page
so the more Google understands about
that web page the more they can put into
the search engine results page so Rich
Snippets is basically some structured
data markup that we can add to our
existing HTML and so if we want to add
Rich Snippets to search engines then how
would you prefer your products to be
displayed well if we have products then
we want to make sure that maybe we have
reviews or maybe we have some other
information in there like links to our
site ok so there's a lot of different
types of Rich Snippets that you know we
can add that Google can recognize and
add to the search engine results so if
you have a product then the
a lot of things we can add like
specifically product reviews so we want
to be able to add more information to
the search engine results by working in
some Rich Snippets so basically the
whole idea is to set up the rich snippet
to drive targeted traffic okay so
because the more information in the SERP
the more likelihood you're going to get
the click and the more likelihood that
click is specific traffic so some of the
benefits of structuring the data for
Rich Snippets are as I mentioned
increasing click-through rates you know
also increasing conversion rates so when
you get the traffic from organic search
to your website if somebody's looking
for specific product and you have a
number of different good reviews showing
up let's just say five stars out of five
stars and you have a hundred reviews
showing five stars then you know
somebody's probably going to send take
some trust in your brand and your
conversion rate probability is going to
go higher
it also helps improve your search engine
visibility because you're adding more
information so in other words the more
Google knows about your page the
likelihood it's going to break that page
and it's more likely that that
information that's contained in that
rich snippet is going to get featured in
either the knowledge graph which is that
graph on the right side or any featured
snippet which usually shows up at the
top of search engine results so in other
words the more information you give
Google the more they can use that
information on their search results page
and there's no disagreement more
information that you have in your search
engine result the likelihood of getting
more traffic increases so for Rich
Snippets you could always start with
images so some of the common properties
that you can add to your product page if
you have a product page is the page
itself is an image you can always start
there you can always add a description
you can always add in ratings and you
can always add and reviews so these are
some of the most common attributes you
can add as a rich snippet so if you add
that Google picks it up it's going to
include that information in the search
results okay some others are offers
prices site links links to your site and
product availability so other
information
be conveyed to google google understands
what you're trying to pass along it's
going to include that in the search
results
so did you know that according to H refs
over ninety nine point five eight
percent of featured pages that have
structured data already ranked in the
top ten list of the Google search
results page so in other words if you
have Rich Snippets in your page your
chances of ranking in the top ten of a
Google result is going to be very very
very good
okay let's talk about tip number five
optimize your site structure for a great
user experience so let's go over some of
the tips that you would do for planning
a good website for SEO and so tip number
one is you want your structure that
follows your site's navigation hierarchy
so obviously homepage interior pages so
depending on what type of site you have
obviously the navigation needs to follow
that sites navigation that site
hierarchy and it all starts with a home
page you want to optimize your home page
to tribe traffic to your product pages
so the home page is nothing more than a
doorway into your website and so the
site's navigation should link to all
those different products so if you have
an e-commerce site with subcategories or
category subcategories then you want to
be able to make sure your navigation
reflects that you want to build a
comprehensive structure for internal
linking as well because when you're from
the home page obviously you want to be
able to easily navigate to other pages
however when you're on other pages you
want to be able to have a link pointing
back to relevant pages and not
necessarily on the home page so this
serves two purposes one for the end user
obviously you want the end user to
navigate through your website seamlessly
right second for the search engines
they're following links they want to be
able to understand how your website
flows and links together so you don't
want a scenario where it's a one-way
street from the home page to interior
pages you want basically a home page to
interior
terior to other relevant interior pages
and that could be a lateral or that can
be a situation where it's a hierarchy
for example homepage category
subcategory sub sub category etc you
want to be able to make sure your site
is constructed in a manner in which the
search ends you can read it so CSS or
cascading style sheets or hypertext
markup language HTML are your two most
common languages that's basically what
browsers load that's what search engines
like to index it just makes it easy for
them to understand what your page is all
about remember we talked about Rich
Snippets in the previous tip Rich
Snippets are nothing more than
supplemental HTML to describe what the
page is all about so that the search
engines can understand that page and
include reviews or include site links in
the search engine results so this is all
based on HTML so the more you provide
the search engines in a more structured
manner via HTML the more the search
engines are going to stay in the page
adding breadcrumbs to your product pages
is also a good practice if you have an
e-commerce site and you have a category
than a sub category then a sub sub
category than a product page what's
probably not a bad idea to make sure you
have a breadcrumb so that was that way
somebody can easily go right back from
the product page to say the category
page or to the sub category page
directly without having to hit the back
button or having to go through the
navigation some good examples I think
Amazon does a good example of using
breadcrumbs giving the amount of
products they have on their site so go
checkout Amazon if you want a good
example for breadcrumbs and then
canonical tags we want to make good use
of canonical tags and that's in order to
avoid duplicate content so an a
canonical tag is nothing more than a
link element basically or an HTML
element that basically prevents
duplicate content issues so in other
words if we have a canonical tag as a
meta tag basically we're telling the
search engines this is the preferred or
canonical version of a web page
is to use this webpage so it signals to
the search engines which page they
should basically index and pay attention
to and avoid at all the other pages that
have similar content so that's the idea
behind a canonical tag so that's a good
best practice and then optimize your
site for desktop and mobile I can't
stress the mobile part enough most users
begin their journey on mobile so if
you're not sure about what the search
engines like it don't like you can
always refer to Google search console
for an example so if you go to Google
search console they have a report called
mobile usability so if we click on
mobile usability you can see what pages
they like what pages they don't like
from a mobile perspective and if you
have errors they're going to tell you
what those errors are so if your website
has text that's too small to read
they're gonna tell you that these are
the pages with this error and so that
allows you to go and address those
errors because from a Google perspective
if you have if a page has a mobile
usability error then Google will not
index that page so leverage Google
search console to get a sense of what
type of errors your site has from a
mobile perspective you also want to
prefer to keep your checkout page simple
so again from an e-commerce perspective
you want to keep the checkout page as
simple as possible for obvious reasons
you want the end-user to have a good
experience and you obviously want the
conversion so when I say keep a checkout
page simple really now with today's
technology you can create a one-page
checkout process you want to optimize
your sitemap so when we talk about
sitemaps we want to make sure that it's
a file and XML file that basically
includes all of our URLs and we can then
turn around and give that sitemap to the
search engines so if you have a sitemap
an XML make sure you go to Google search
console so if I go to Google search
console and I click on sitemaps I can
just simply just tell Google where my
sitemap is low
and when they recognize that sitemap
they're gonna be able to basically index
the URLs from that site map so we could
see here or how many URLs they discover
and how many they index so make sure you
create the sitemap in an XML format
submit the sitemap via Google search
console and then you can go back and see
how many pages they've indexed versus
how many you've submitted and you want
to make sure that sitemap is dynamic
meaning any time you publish your Rao
that URL is added to the sitemap fixing
broken links so broken links is not
something you want but it's something
every website has it's unavoidable
you know people publish pages all the
time there's test pages there's all
sorts of reasons why a site has broken
links you want to be able to address
those and again going back to Google
search console we can basically see just
by looking at some reports what pages
have broken links which ones don't
so we could certainly look at search
console but get information about
basically what pages are broken which
ones on it and then we want to prefer
predictive searches and integrate
product type of graphic errors on your
search bar so basically have a search
bar that's the best practice but
anticipate knowing what people are
typing in so that means maybe going into
Google Analytics and looking at the
search terms report so we can go into
analytics and look at search terms to
get a sense of what people are searching
for but you know when we talk about
integrating product type of graphic
errors we're talking also about fonts so
we want to make sure we're using the
latest fonts so that we don't run into
any issues on our website people not
being able to read based on a specific
font that you're using and then as a
best practice what I found and this is
not necessarily for everyone but using a
live chat widget sometimes helps in fact
I would even go beyond sometimes I'm
most the time again depending on your
business but I see most businesses now
have live chat enabled and so basically
having live chat enables
somebody who has a question to
immediately reach out to somebody versus
picking up the phone versus sending an
email
it's just instantaneous gratification in
some ways so inserting live chat on a
website is more common practice than not
nowadays given it lends to a better user
experience tip number six improve your
page speed and reduce the bounce rate so
let's talk about page speed and how page
speed correlates with higher bounce rate
if it's a high page load and so
according to crazy
page speed is an important overlook the
CEO tactic because for every second
delay and page load can result in 11%
fewer page views 60% decrease in
customer satisfaction 7 percent decline
in conversion rate so you know you can
see here regardless of how specific the
numbers are when you have a page that
loads slow you're going to have lower
user engagement in a poor user
experience so you have to pay attention
to page speed and so since 2010 Google
has been using page speed as a factor
for page ranking in the search engine
results so here are some tips to focus
on making sure your pages are optimal in
terms of speed so enable browser caching
ok you can reduce plugins if you're
using WordPress as an example you know
disable plugins you're not using get
using a simple website design going back
to tip number 5 stick with CSS and HTML
don't do anything fancy in terms of
technology because it's only gonna
complicate matters optimize your code
minify files meaning hey if you're not
using any code just get rid of it
because code has to execute and that
slows down page load time so if your
website has numerous CSS and JavaScript
files basically minify and combine them
and there's that's what we're talking
about there you know you don't
necessarily need a lot of you know
JavaScript on your page you can leverage
Google tag manager or you know other
features that help minimize
the number of JavaScript files you have
and so you can also get some of these
ideas by going into Google Analytics so
in analytics under behavior under site
speed under page timings you can
basically see how quick each page loads
and then if you click on speed
suggestions right below page timings
what happens is Google is gonna actually
give you some suggested ways to increase
speed so if we lit this report load
we'll be able to see some speed
suggestions per page and so here you can
see for example the home page has an
average page load time of four point
eight nine seconds you can see right
next to that we have PageSpeed
suggestions seven total so if we click
on that basically what it's going to do
is going to launch another Google
product called PageSpeed insights and
what PageSpeed insights is going to do
is it's going to analyze the page in
question whether that be the home page
or in a chariot page and what they're
actually going to do is not only analyze
the desktop version of your website but
also the mobile version and so now we
can see opportunities to improve our
page speed by making sure the image is a
properly sized making sure server
response time is changed again defer
unused CSS not using CSS that's or
getting rid of CSS or minifying it so
there's lots of things you can do and
again this is desktop and mobile so on
the mobile side we could see some of the
other issues too that are causing high
page load and so analytics site speed
reports PageSpeed insights are good ways
to get an idea really excellent ways to
really address page load time issues so
again these are just some of the common
issues with page load time there could
be other factors so leaning on those
PageSpeed insights reports will
definitely help reduce page load time so
basically according to Google a website
should have you know time to first byte
lesser than 200 milliseconds
milliseconds are very very fast so case
your website is slower than 200
millisecond
such as 500 milliseconds or more you
need to improve it so you don't even
have to measure it by milliseconds you
can even go by seconds which is what
most of us count time and again you can
see that simply going into the speed
suggestions report in Google Analytics
so ideally in terms of seconds you want
something that about you know four
seconds or less three seconds or less
obviously as fast as possible so case
study Walmart Walmart reported the
following results so Walmart experienced
a two percent increasing inversions for
every one second of page speed
improvement so think about that there's
definitely correlation between page load
time and speed so in conversions and
user engagement so the quicker your page
loads the higher the engagement
so with that improvement they also
experienced an increment in revenue so
meaning the pages load people had a
better user experience they were able to
checkout easier and that led to more
revenue so they were able to measure
revenue against milliseconds and that's
something you can certainly do in
analytics you can correlate revenue with
bounce rate you can correlate revenue
with page speed a tip number 7 built
quality links and increase their domain
authority of your website so Google's
top 3 search ranking factors includes
link building so you need to have
quality links from quality sites
pointing to your site and so that's a
factor in terms of ranking so that's
falls under off page SEO you need to
build references and links on quality
sites and so building quality links to
your content can give your product or
category pages or even content or blog
post a boost in the SERPs so it's all
about quality over quantity so it's
always building quality links not
quantity so let's talk about what kind
of strategies you should implement so if
you implement these strategies then
you're going to likely see a
lived in the SERPs so earn backlinks
from relevant and authoritative webpages
so what's authoritative well
authoritative is subjected to some
degree but it's also measurement in
others so you can use Moz as a good tool
to measure page Authority or domain
Authority so if I go into Moz Moz has a
page and domain Authority score between
1 and 100 and so you can actually see
what sites have good domain or page
Authority just by entering in the domain
so relevant you obviously want to rank
to something that's relevant so if
you're in the food industry something
food-related you want to promote your
content regularly on social media so
social media I always considered
although low-hanging fruit when it comes
to backlinking you know there's so many
different social media platforms
available Facebook LinkedIn Twitter
there's so many varieties from images to
Pinterest and Instagram to video being
YouTube so there's lots of ways to get
your content out on social media that
will allow you to not only promote your
band build a community but also
establish a reference back to that page
you can opt for guest blogging ok so you
can reach out to another blogger and
blog on that platform
it could be reciprocal as well a blogger
can certainly you know blog on your
platform and have a link back and it
works both ways
influencer marketing so influencer
marketing is working with somebody who
has a large amount of followers who can
influence those followers to you know
mention you in a hash tag linked to your
particular product or brand or even
drive traffic to your site so you want
to take advantage of social media
platforms and start your own page as
well so Facebook is a good example it
can be having a YouTube channel if
you're into video you can certainly set
up a YouTube channel build a following
around YouTube as well so always start
your own page if that's the platform of
choice the last thing you should do is
set up a page on social media and not
keep it updated you can certainly
participate in 4
you can participate in other websites
like kora or reddit that's very you know
content based content driven user driven
I always recommend starting your own
blog blog is a good way to not only
generate content but it's a good way to
incorporate different types of content
so you could set up different types of
content in categories it's a good way to
incorporate different assets like images
and video that's a good way to get users
engaged by having comments or having
social share buttons it's a good way to
leverage that content onto other social
media platforms so there's lots of
benefits to blogging very few cons the
only con would be a time constraint but
it's better to have one blog post in one
month consistently than not blogging at
all so getting listed on high quality
link directories like Yahoo directory is
still a way to add a link from a high
quality site and then make use of broken
link building so again on the last tip
we mentioned search console search
console certainly has reports available
for you that allow you to see what pages
on your site are no longer there and
allow you to see what pages they're
linking from you can also do
testimonials there's lots of ways to
generate quality links in a way you
almost have to get creative but creative
in a way that's going to generate
quality not quantity quality is the key
so even if it's one source whether that
be somebody else's blog so be it as long
as its quality that's what counts so
let's talk about some of the key
takeaways from today's tips
so remember tip number one we want to
opt for smarter ways to do keyword
research so remember we want to look at
volume we want to look at competition we
want to create things put them in a
spreadsheet so we want to be smarter and
which in the way in which we choose our
keyword tip number two remember publish
high quality content to get more traffic
when we say high quality content
remember break up the content use
different assets organize and structure
it you know make sure it's answers
these questions then we talked about in
tip number three analyzing your meta
tags and URLs so we want to make sure
that title tag meta descriptions are
creative using modifiers like numbers or
promotions you know we don't want to go
over character counts we want to make
them unique and distinct so that
somebody clicks on them then we talked
about Rich Snippets and tip number four
remember Rich Snippets are just
additional HTML that communicates the
search engine so the search engines can
understand exactly what's on your page
so if you have recipes if you have
reviews if you have videos if you have
images the operating is all these things
can be added to the SERPs just by
communicating with the search engines
vyas Rich Snippets tip 5 optimize your
site structure we want to make sure that
you know you have good in bound links
you want to make sure you incorporate
breadcrumbs you want to make sure users
can navigate your site more easily and
then at tip number 6 if your pages load
fast then it's going to enhance the user
experience it's going to increase user
engagement and increase conversions and
then tip number 7 we want to build
quality link quality to increase the
domain authority so remember we can use
mods to measure domain authority it's
all about quality whether that be via
I'm fluence or marketing guest blogging
directories social media setting up a
social media page there's always
something you could be doing to generate
a quality link to your website thank you
for attending today's session if you
have any more information please visit
simply learn com
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here